I have a very strange situation to talk
about with you regarding tulsi gabbard
gabbard's a member of congress she
represents Hawaii she's also running for
the Democratic presidential nomination
and it turns out that she's advising a
Koch brother funded think tank which to
begin with is strange for a supposed
Bernie Kratt but also the more
interesting element of it or maybe more
concerning is that she left the fact
that she's involved with this think tank
out of her financial disclosure form for
2017 so let's walk it through Gabbard is
an advisor to the Center for
statesmanship at Catholic University and
the Koch brothers made a big deal when
this think tank was established they
gave a 2.35 billion dollar grant out of
their foundation to create this and on
their website Tulsi Gabbard is listed as
an advisor okay so the Koch brothers
they push right-wing libertarian sort of
ideology we know that Y is a Bernie
supporting Democrat advising them well
one explanation would be that the
libertarian anti interventionism sort of
overlaps with Tulsi gabbard's apparent
anti interventionism and that that kind
of brings them together with the Koch
brothers and with this think-tank except
that that's not even really accurate
because Gabbard has said many times
before that she's a hawk on terrorism so
she says she's against intervention when
what she really means is she's against
certain interventions that she doesn't
find aligned with her views like for
example leaving dictator Bashar al-assad
in power we could debate is he a good
guy or a bad guy but that's a separate
question from should the u.s. be
involved in regime change or not or
whatever but her position really seems
to be intervention when it suits her
particular political views and
priorities rather than simply for or
against intervention but anyway we could
argue for a while about whether Tulsi
Gabbard is a good fit in this think tank
or isn't a good fit but that's not
really the point I'm just this
establishing that she's an advisor the
concern is that she didn't list this
advisory on her 2017 financial
disclosure now you might say David hold
on a second it might be an unpaid
advisory if she didn't get paid there
wouldn't be anything to disclose right
well it's possible that it's unpaid I
don't know I might think tend to think
it's paid but it actually doesn't matter
unpaid positions with organizations
including educational institutions like
this one must be disclosed regardless of
whether you get paid now gabbard's
office was asked for an explanation as
to why this was not on her financial
disclosure she didn't give an answer and
this is actually becoming a trend with
Tulsi Gabbard she claims to be about
transparency but she's not actually
practicing transparency another example
of this is a couple of years ago in 2017
Tulsi Gabbard went to Lebanon and Syria
and met with Bashar al-assad who is the
Syrian dictator accused of using
chemical weapons against his own people
initially she refused to say who even
paid for the trip at the time her office
was asked multiple times and they said
it wasn't funded by tax payers that's
all were willing to say we eventually
found out because two brothers Elli and
Bassam kawaman said they paid for the
trip that the trip was actually paid for
by these brothers who are connected to a
group linked to the Assad regime and
accused of pretty significant
anti-semitism of course both claims that
in their defense the Coen brothers deny
so this is a growing trend with Tulsi
Gabbard and I don't know whether anyone
in our audience is still even thinking
about supporting Tulsi Gabbard for the
2020 Democratic primary nomination I've
said before I don't get the appeal I've
identified who are my top sort of two
three four contenders but for me this is
just the furthest thing within the
Democratic Party that I could see myself
supporting and the lack of financial
disclosure is certainly a concern
to put it lightly and if anyone wants to
explain to me I mean listen I've I want
to tell you what the world is like as I
see it okay if someone wants to get in
touch with me and say David here's why
the lack of disclosure should not be at
all concerning to you here's why the
lack of transparency around the meeting
with Bashar al-assad should not be
concerning to you I'm all ears
let me know why it is that I shouldn't
be concerned by those things